Nicholas Dave welcome back to the forge
you know dachies look fantastic your
blades will now be put through a series
of three tests up first
the kill test Doug
all right weaponsmiths I will take your
nodachi and cut this pig up in different
sections until I ran out of pig all
right Nicholas you up first you ready
I'm ready let's do this of course I'm
nervous there's a lot on the line today
I really just hope my sword performs I I
really hope I don't get a failure I hope
it doesn't break or bend
nice
I'll kill him
all right Nicholas it is a very sharp
Blade with a nice way to maneuver with
it because of the lightness that you
have the handle construction is
beautiful the only thing that I was
worried about were the pins that you
have in here they're protruding but most
importantly it will kill nice all right
Dave it's your turn you ready yes sir
and here we go
it's not as sharp as yours Dave the
weight of the blades a little bit
forward for me to be very accurate on
every strike but anything that this
blade touches and cuts it will kill
thank you sir
hello gents welcome to the pull and part
Smash and chop to test the strength and
durability of your Edge as well as the
overall construction of your nodachis
I'm going to be chopping away at these
poles and then I'm going to take aim at
these parts
Nicholas you're up first you ready
I'm ready let's do it
[Music]
well Nick first things first this thing
is amazing to swing I get the feeling
like I could cleave armies with this
thing that being said
right here near the tip there's a pretty
significant role you can hear it
these pins that are sticking out pretty
proud they kind of bit into my fingers
as I was swinging it but well done thank
you
if you're up you ready yes sir all right
in a blade this long there's so much
that can go wrong you just don't know
until the judges start working it
foreign
[Music]
held up pretty well there's a little
darling but no big deflections the
handle is comfortable well done thank
you sir
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test now in this test we've
decided to scale up the water bottles to
the size of the nodachi sharp blade
should pass right through them a dull
blade or a chip blade might catch them
push them tear them up we're gonna find
out Nicholas you're up you ready I'm
ready
this is nerve-wracking it's a nail biter
there's fifty thousand dollars on the
line you can't tell I'm nervous scared
and excited I don't know what to think
nice
[Music]
Nicholas your blade is remarkably light
um your balance on this blade is great
nicely done on this weapon well done
it's a very sharp light
all right Dave you're up are you ready
I'm ready okay
it's like a roller coaster ride right
now
I'm up and I'm nervous I'm calm and I'm
nervous and I'm like back and forth back
and forth
[Music]
and sharp
okay
all right Dave your handle construction
super comfortable I like the size of it
it felt really good and overall it's
sharp good job thank you sir
blade Smiths this Tournament of
Champions has been an extraordinary
competition in weaponsmithing but the
judge's deliberation is complete and
they've made their final decision
only one of you can be our champion
[Music]
Dave
congratulations you are the forged in
fire Tournament champion
Nicholas I want you to know there has
been no finer margin by which we've
declared a champion you did the armors
proud unfortunately
blade didn't make the cut during the
testing we all noticed the protruding
pegs from your handle and your blade did
take damage during the strength test it
was a tough decision but at this time I
have to ask you to please surrender your
nodachi I'm really proud of the weapon I
made
it never feels good to lose
but I enjoyed myself immensely through
all this stress through all the drama I
came to represent the Armor's class and
I think I did a good job at that I hope
my brothers are proud of me Dave
congratulations you are the forged and
fire Tournament champion beating out 15
other competitors to win our biggest
prize ever 50
000 and you look like a badass with that
weapon right now
Dave please present your nodachi to the
judges I believe I've done a modern
metal workers proud the skill level with
this last competition was off the charts
my name is Dave parthmore and I've just
won fifty thousand dollars
[Music]
late Smith's a hanzo's katana's first
duty is to kill you find out what kind
of lethal damage your weapon will do I
will take your Katana and deliver
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
all right Mike New York first are you
ready yes sir students
all the years up until now has gone into
this play it's not just a five-day blade
it's a 15-year blade
two three
[Music]
yes
Mike your Edge is razor sharp but more
importantly there's bone on your Edge
but your Edge shouldn't roll the nut
ship and your blade stayed true
overall sir your blade
will kill
thank you
Justin you ready yes sir let's do this
I'm really hoping that I don't see any
damage happening to my blade I know that
I have a hard Edge and I know I have a
soft steel spine to support that hard
Edge and it shouldn't be moving anywhere
foreign
[Music]
the balance of your blade is very good
it's light it's fast it's easily
maneuverable
but
when steel meets the skull there were
some problems
your blade because serious Bend
also on the edge right here you took
some chipping
but overall looking at the dummy I think
your weapon will definitely kill thank
you
gentlemen
the second duty of a Hanzo Katana is
that it is to be sharp it is said that
the Hanzo Katana is as sharp as a
thousand razor blades
now sharp blade should cut cleanly
through its tummy mats a dulled blade
will crush Bend or get hung up a doll
blade is not a Hanzo katana
Mike you're up first you ready for this
yes I'm ready let's do this
going into this I'm a little bit nervous
because I know that I went through a lot
of bone and so probably the edge isn't
there that was there when it started
thank you
your blade sir is sharp it cut cleanly
to the thickest of our tatami mats but
on the backhand slice it did not cut
completely though overall sir your sword
will cut it
thank you Tristan your turn you ready
ready as I'll ever be sir let's do this
if one more thing goes wrong with my
Katana I'm definitely going to be going
home
[Music]
sleep
well Tristan your Edge is sharp
if you cut through the tummy mats my
concern is the strength of your blade
it picked up another Bend now you have
two bends on your blade especially right
here close to the guard
Tristan this Hollywood competition has
been exciting and dramatic you've been
at the epicenter of all of that drama
nobody is questioning the strength of
your character however the strength of
your blade is such that we can no longer
continue to test it
for that reason I have to ask you to
please leave the forge
yes sir
I guess I just couldn't flip there
objectively speaking one of the blades
is better than the other and it's clear
to see because one of them is straight I
may not be Fortune fire Champion but
second place isn't bad for somebody
who's never done this before
Mike you were an Unstoppable force in
this competition and your hatari Hanzo
thousand layer Katana is absolutely
deadly earning you the title of forged
and fire champion
check for 10 grand good job brother I
came here to show myself that I can make
a blade worthy of undergoing this type
of punishment I am forged and fire
champion and it feels awesome
the naginata was a Japanese weapon known
for its long-range cutting ability you
see how sharp your naginata is I will
take your weapon and I'll attempt to cut
through these tatami mats and a side of
beef Theo you're up first you ready yeah
I think so let's do this
geez all right I'm nervous the area
where the guard meets the Tang is a
little narrow which could result in
bending
maybe a snapping
I'll take it yeah all right I just want
to point out that after that test your
blade has a slight Bend to it it almost
cut all the way through one of the Tommy
mats when it came to the side of beef it
cut cleanly through your blade feels
good it's got a nice weight to it a nice
balance overall your naginata we'll cut
good job thank you Joe you're up next
you ready oh yeah let's do this let's do
it
I feel like Theo did really good in the
Tommy match slice and exceptionally well
through the V slice
and I'm pretty nervous at this point on
how my blade is going to perform
[Music]
oh well done man yeah
I would say I'm ahead in the game I've
performed a little bit better than what
Theos did
well Joe you have a very sharp blade but
we now have an issue
when I cut through the tatami mat your
handle at the seams here came apart
your handle seam has opened up
and not only that it picked up some
cracks on this side that runs all the
way down here and on the other side
hairline fracture that goes down this
way the seams are big enough to where I
can actually put my fingernail through
them that is a critical failure
and for purposes of safety we cannot
continue to test your weapon
there's nothing we can't do nothing
blade Smith's the judges have determined
that there's no reason to deliberate
Joe due to the catastrophic failure of
your weapons handled
you may now leave the arena
it's not the way I wanted to win
I wouldn't say I have regrets
say if I go back and change some of the
things I did I would have gone with a
different wood something that was less
likely to open up in a crack I feel like
I'm in a round room and I'm looking for
a corner to cry in
pretty tough loss
Theo congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
that ten thousand dollar prize good job
you know what I like about your Blade
the way you reinforce your handle
because the power you generate with that
saved it
congratulations thank you sir I am
elated to be the fortunate fire Champion
it's not the way I wanted to win
but I'll take it I came here the
youngest smallest person and I won for
the shortest guy I certainly came out on
top
all right blade Smiths to find out how
deadly your weapons are I will take your
weapon and deliver some killing slashes
and thrust on this big carcass
Rich here first you ready for this I
hope so right now I'm a little anxious
to see Doug swing my blade but worried
about the bones we'll see how it cuts
them though
foreign
[Music]
balance it's a very light blade well as
you can see it really tapers down here
it's very thin right here so there's a
little bit of a kick on your blade where
it's slightly bent now your Edge it is
very sharp your tip is pointed enough to
penetrate but more importantly it will
kill all right all right Elijah your
turn sir you ready I am
Richie's blade annihilated that pig I
need to come in with at least that level
of performance so you know there's a
little bit of nervousness there
[Music]
[Music]
all right Elijah every slash cut very
deep into this big carcass
the thrusts were easy enough to go
through it's a sharp edge and it will
Keel thank you
[Music]
blade Smith's welcome to the strength
test
the strength and overall construction of
your gunters I'm going to take each of
them and deliver slices to this heavy
dense bamboo
all right Richie at first you ready
I hope so
oh
wow
[Music]
all right nice job Richie okay your Edge
held up very nicely
balanced well
we do have a little concern your wrap is
coming undone on us that's a bit of an
issue
but overall nicely done
how you doing Elijah good ready to do
this I am so am I let's do it yeah don't
wear yourself out though
maybe I should have kept my mouth shut
because I know he's really gonna try to
destroy my blade on the bamboo
[Music]
nice job Elijah
your Edge is still sharp all the way
down the blade
you do have a slight
slight Bend right there in the blade but
I mean it's very minor everything's
tight
very nicely done thank you
[Music]
all right blade spits General
yamashita's gold is somewhere in the
Philippines and if it's there I want a
shot at it
so to test the sharpness of your weapon
I will take your gunto and cut through
these burlap bags Richie you're up first
you ready ready let's do this
three three
good job all right Richard we found gold
your blade it's sharp with every slash
it cuts through the bags the only thing
is the more I use it
the more it's coming unraveled but
overall sir your blade
will cut
right Elijah's not here next you ready I
am let's do this
[Music]
well Elijah your edges cut all the way
through and we struck gold a very fine
strong Edge a very fine sharp edge for
this tester it will cut thank you
Richie Elijah if only one of you can be
the forged and fire champion and that
champion is
Elijah congratulations you're the new
Fortune fire champion
Richie unfortunately your gunto didn't
make the cut Richie you brought us a
sharp strong sword but the dimensions
and scale are off the blade tapers to a
point and only has a curve at the tip
the blade is offset to the handle in our
test the handle came unraveled I
understand
well Richard at this time I have to ask
you to please surrender your gunto
it's more grit than you think but I have
no regrets I've met some good friends
and some very good blade Smith I have no
trouble coming in second place to any of
them
I feel good I've enjoyed it
Elijah you are the new forest and fire
champion and that's a title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
please present your blade to the judges
still sinking in that I won forged in
fire my wife pushed me into doing this
competition so I really appreciate her
support and I'm really happy I could win
so it's pretty awesome
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your sonigurami will do I will take your
weapons and stab and try to snag this
ballistics dummy Rita you're ready for
this hi
foreign
[Music]
the times you have here penetrates the
hook you have here will rip this person
apart and more importantly your weapon
kill
all right Justin your attorney you ready
to have fun yes sir
all right Justin the times you have here
it's more of a stabbing kind rather than
a grabbing this is a grabbing weapon but
that hook does grab onto that overall
sir your weapon
killed
alright blades nuts it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks about those
ice blocks due to your weapons and Rita
you're up first you get points for theme
I mean
you ready
it doesn't matter right oh it doesn't
matter
foreign
[Music]
got a little bit more of a bend in this
one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in definitely held up
did his job good job
all right Justin your turn you ready yes
I am
thank you
all right so you survived the strength
test this is a very strong well-built
head for this but it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching I mean I'm
not sure how effective it would be at
snagging the opponent but uh it's a
Devastator it certainly did the job good
job
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
sharpness test the Sandman Pierce and
capture
to test the sharpness I will take your
weapon Pierce and try to control this
Sandman we let you up first you ready
for this
all right Rita the points you have on
your times here definitely penetrate
when you thrust into that but it doesn't
Slice on the way out or capture as well
as it should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut and control
all right Justin your turn so you ready
yes I am
oh
that's not good
well Justin we have a problem yes sir
this wasn't pinned was it no the impact
from all these tests loosened it up and
of course it came off
Justin you brought in a beautifully
crafted weapon however you've suffered a
catastrophic failure in our final test
and unfortunately you cannot be our
Forge and fire Champion congratulations
coming on Forest and fire I proved what
I wanted to that people with physical
limitations can do as well as anybody
I'll put my all into it and I feel like
I made a good weapon but uh just came up
short on a little bit of the fit and
finish and other than that I'm happy
with it
[Music]
Rita congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations how do you feel
right now
come on forward and Shake our hands
good job it's been a very positive and
uplifting experience to be able to do
something amazing like this I hope this
will help me become an inspiration to
kids because I can say look if you see
something and you want to try it give it
a try
hey weeblows your scout leader is the
new Fortune fire Champion I'm bringing
it home can I have a group hug please
oh my God
[Music]
gentlemen it's time for the bullet split
now if you pass this test you get to
join a very elite club our bulletproof
sword Club
look at that damn I think that did it
yep now to handle this test we've got
our own 15-year military veteran and
deadly weapon will Willis well I've
never shot a blade before and why would
I the only people that I know that would
shoot a blade because all the judges on
forged and Fire
they doing it hit it yeah I had to hit
it blades in one piece good job
though you did take a bit of a
deflection there are two small rolls on
either side of the deflection but you
survived welcome to the club thanks sir
all right Cullen you're up are you ready
shoot the [ __ ] out of it
isn't it yes and split all over the
place okay Colin you can clearly see
where the bullet hit the blade little
bits of bullet right there but there's
no deflection to your Edge
welcome to the club your blade survived
thank you all right next up is the kill
test and for that I'll give it to Doug
all right bladesmits this is the kill
test Mickey you're up first you ready
for this you know what let's do this
I've designed my blade to do one thing
slice cut and Keel
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right Mickey suck about your Katana
right here to be able to wield the sword
this size the handle is what drives the
blade it's hard to get very accurate
because it's big but what I love about
your blade is how sharp your Edge is it
cut into the scalp pieces of it came off
and what's important about this Katana
is
it will kill thank you sir good job all
right Collins your turn you ready for
this
let's do this
foreign
it's very hard to grab a complete grip
on this but you have a very sharp tip
that punctures easily into this
ballistics dummy but it doesn't lacerate
on the way out
it did crush the skull and any kind of
damage like this done to anybody
it will kill thank you
all right blade Smiths next up the
sharpness test the quad sugarcane Cuts
Mickey you're up first you ready for
this hell yeah
that was good man awesome good as you
can see all the way through with each
swing that I do with this Blade The Edge
is razor sharp the balance of this is
good I can follow through and still
control the blade and it will cut good
job thank you sir
all right Collins your turn sir are you
ready let's do it
good
as you can see when we start with the
handle your wrap is starting to come
undone now your Edge there is no Edge on
the blade the sheer weight alone and in
a very thick obtuse blade here it more
crushes the sugar gains than cuts it so
you have the honor of saying it will
crush
blade Smith's judges made their final
decision only one of you can be our new
forged and fire champion and that
champion is Mickey congratulations you
are the new forged and fire champion and
that is a title that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
brother
man I am the forest and fire champion
just made a ten thousand dollar sword
I'm happier than a tick and a [ __ ] dog
buddy
[Music]